I do not make enough to live on my own I
would not make enough to pay rent water
electric and eat all by myself I would
not be capable of doing that 20 years
ago when you were getting started you
could live on your own 20 years ago when
you first started you were able to do
everything that I'm now struggling to do
let me add another perspective here
you've been working for 20 years you
have 20 years of working experience
behind your belt you have 20 years of
experience in a career that has allowed
you to gain raises to get more money to
profit you in an economy that you
created you could sit here and you can
call Jen Z lazy all you want but I've
been working my tail end off just to
barely make it by and respectfully I
don't want to do that for the rest of my
life that part she says right at the
beginning of the video she says I'm
working 8 hours a day I'm working 40
hours a week and I can't even afford all
of the things that I need to live alone
why does she want to live
alone yeah